need to dream big i mean you cannot  dream big enough  i'm telling you you can't dream big  enough  you can do more than you're doing  but you can't do more than you're doing  if you hang around with little thinkers  that could be your family members it  could be your friends could be people  you're going to school with and hanging  out with look there's a time and a place  to hang out with those people  can't pick your family i mean they say  you can't i wonder sometimes we don't  actually do the picking  and just show up there but i'll save  that for another conversation  but i do know once  once you get with your family the family  that you picked or they picked or  however that might work the selection  process  wherever you went to school or go to  school or where you grew up or how you  grew up or religion you grew up in or  whether you're white or black or brown  male or female question is always going  to be  what can you do  to do more with your life